[Música]
debido a las restricciones establecidas
para luchar contra la pandemia las
fashion weeks vuelven a realizarse
digitalmente no hay desfiles de moda o
eventos no hay ágapes o encuentros los
compradores y periodistas por igual
están invitados a sentarse cómodamente
en sus sofás para ver películas a través
de las redes sociales y es inútil
ocultarlo es un poco aburrido por otro
lado es fascinante entender cómo se
realizan estas películas de moda el
juego en diseñador de moda parisino luis
gabriel noche y figura por primera vez
en la lista oficial de desfiles de moda
masculina para el invierno de 2021 48
horas antes de la emisión en las redes
sociales retoca a sus nuevos modelos
luís gabriel a más sobre todo la
literatura todas sus colecciones están
inspiradas en libros
no tenemos un proceso con las cosas que
son decorativas en comparación con la
inspiración básica es decir los libros
ya no sirven de una manera muy
pragmática la gama de colores de la
colección o sea que todos los colores
que se evocan en el libro los
transcribimos después en la gama de
colores para las prendas el contexto
histórico también nos da una primera
indicación de los años también lo que el
escritor lleva puesto luego por supuesto
intentamos transcribir toda la atmósfera
del libro y también hay otro nivel desde
los materiales
en estos tiempos como no inspirarse en
franz kafka
el proceso porque para mí estaba
relacionado con todos los grandes
juicios que hemos visto últimamente en
francia ya sea los atentados de hampton
o por la brutalidad policial y también
se relacionan por ejemplo con lo que
estamos viviendo con la vacuna existe
una especie de pesadez administrativa en
francia de la que se habla desde hace
años que experimentamos a diario y que
nadie parece poder resolver es algo
increíble en el caso del proceso de
kafka realmente queríamos transmitir esa
atmósfera tan fría así que usé una gama
de colores muy apagados con colores
extremadamente clásicos como el negro
blanco el gris
en fin emociones colores bastante
seguros y jugar realmente en tonos
bastante elegantes the page y re
transcribir toda esta noción de oficina
administrativa con los marcadores con el
metal muy frío de las sillas también
tenemos toda esta atmósfera que es un
poco brillante con las luces de neón que
vemos mucho en los tribunales o en la
administración así que como resultado
tener este verde así muy pálido muy frío
que resalta
entonces por ejemplo hay toda una noción
de violencia en esta colección que se
manifiesta también en los acabados y
tratamientos de las prendas de punto que
son muy agresivos para las piezas pero
que constituyen un valor añadido luis
gabriel lucha y rechaza todos los
matices de una ropa deportiva chic
trabajados en lana o en jersey yo
siempre trabajo las colecciones tocando
los materiales de siempre creó prendas
para que sean cómodas y que la gente se
sienta bien en ellas que les permita
revelarse y decirse a sí mismas
bueno puedo aceptarme así y
especialmente en este momento me parece
que el tacto está más ausente digamos en
nuestra vida cotidiana desde hace unos
años o sea ya no podemos encontrarnos ya
no podemos tocar pues tenemos una
verdadera distancia social y para mí
precisamente la ropa puede restablecer
este vínculo
para darle cuerpo a su colección luís
gabriel no recurrió a modelos clásicos
sino a bailarines 24 horas antes del día
d en el centro nacional de danza en
punta al norte de parís el coreógrafos
ahora visitan dispone de dos horas para
improvisar un ballet moderno siguiendo
las reglas del arte
me fascinan los brazos me parece que los
bailarines tienen brazos extraordinarios
a veces más que las piernas y yo hago
mucho trabajo de brazos yo mismo como
bailarín soy muy serpentina si puedo
decirlo así nunca
seguramente debido a mis orígenes mis
padres irán y creo que se crearon
puentes en algún momento pero si lo que
me interesa mucho es todo lo que se
mueve los brazos toda la parte superior
del cuerpo
me parece que aporta una energía que no
tenemos
además también tuve la suerte es el
alumno de dejar a quien también le
fascinan los brazos trabaja mucho la
mímica todos los movimientos de las
manos ya que también era su adn mis
influencias son también la de los
bailarines de hoy en día muchos cada vez
más bailarines de hip hop también así
que todo lo que sea trabajo kraft de
energía muy aislado en el suelo también
me interesa mucho como
y es el gran día en un palais de tokyo
desierto unas 50 personas trabajan en el
peinado el maquillaje las luces y los
retoques de las prendas el escenario es
un túnel de espejos y direccionales que
simbolizan la noción kafkiana del
infinito del absurdo es un espectáculo
viviente que durará 10 minutos se
grabará en una sola toma para ser
emitido una hora después en las redes
sociales es todo muy intelectual el
postulado de la marca es muy intelectual
pero al final sigue siendo ropa o sea la
gente viene porque las chaquetas bonitas
porque el material es súper bonito el
corte también y es cómoda y también
porque nosotros creemos en ciertos
valores que tratamos de representar como
la honestidad la transparencia el hecho
de que tengamos un circuito corto que
favorecemos los materiales naturales que
todo en la tienda es de origen orgánico
que trabajamos siempre con los mismos
colaboradores desde hace años es todo un
equipo y una ética de trabajo también y
si es una invitación al debate además lo
que hacemos cada vez es una cierta
propuesta es una mirada de un momento
dado de lo que
podría haber pasado y la literatura
permite una cierta elegancia no ser
demasiado directos al hablar de estos
temas
perdón sin sé que hablo mucho la moda es
la caída de los materiales la precisión
de los cortes la coherencia de los
colores es la exaltación del sentido del
tacto las películas lo digital esa es
otra historia